[Musik]
hallo leute heute zeigen wir euch
vokabeln rund um das thema haare
schneiden und glücklicherweise habe ich
gerade einen haarschnitt ihr habt es
gesehen
es kann ganz schön nervös machen wenn
man zum friseur geht und nicht weiß wie
man auf deutsch beschreiben soll was man
denn für eine frisur haben möchte das
kann in kleinen katastrophen enden
deshalb zeigen wir euch heute welche
vokabeln ihr nutzen könnt so was
brauchen wir heute zum haarigen 1
zunächst muss man überlegen möchte man
die haare nass oder trocken schneiden
wenn man die haare nass schneidet wäscht
man die zunächst mit haarshampoo und
eventuell auch eine haarspülung dann
brauchen wir eine bürste um die haare
ordentlich durchzulüften einen stil kam
wo man auf einer seite die hertha team
trennen kann
und auf der anderen seite die haare
schön gerade kennen kann um sie dann zu
schneiden
dann haben wir noch so eine haarspange
oder auch ein haarband was ich jetzt
gerade im habe um die einzelnen partien
weg zu trennen
und das allerwichtigste eine haare
schneidet er ganz wichtig speziell zum
haareschneiden und wir sind super profis
wir haben sogar einen umhang einem
umhang damit die haare nicht alle auf
den klamotten kleben oder andere haut
losgeht so nun stelle ich euch den
friseur heute vor
wer wird mir heute die haare schneiden
es ist nett
mit bist du bereit mir die haare zu
schneiden
ja ich bin bereits etwa beim friseur
werden einem meistens zunächst die haare
gewaschen
ob man die haare nass oder trocken
schneidet entscheidet man je nach
zustand des haares an lockige haare hat
man glatte haare hat man dünne haare
oder hat man dicke haare und dann wenn
man die haare wäscht hört man auch einen
ganz bestimmten satz ist die
wassertemperatur angenehm für sie
so fragt der friseure die friseurin ab
ob das wasser vielleicht zu heiß oder zu
kalt ist
ich mache jetzt meine haare mal ganz
schnell macht damit loslegen kann so
meine haare sind etwas nass ich habe sie
gut durchgekämpft damit wir jetzt
anfangen können zu schneiden
mitch macht sich gerade bereit ich habe
die haare alle in einer länge
deswegen werden wir einfach nur einen
zentimeter abschneiden okay nicht mehr
manchmal trage ich auch einen stufen
schnitt mit verschiedenen stufen aber
jetzt sind die haare gleich lang
ja und das machen wir jetzt mit habe ich
bist kannst du mal gucken
ich war doch mal ob die haare auch
gesund sind und meine kopfhaut kann es
mir meine kopfhörer angucken ist sie
trocken
und da hat sie genug feuchtigkeit schau
doch mal
ich würde gerne wissen was meine haare
alles gesund ist mit schau doch mal
bitte nein mit schmidt den friseur um
hagen
wir müssen noch um müssen noch umlegen
wozu haben wir dann extra
[Musik]
wasser
so mit schneidet jetzt die spitzen und
dann später haben sie noch gucken was
wir mit meinem pony machen
ich habe nämlich einen pony einem langen
pony den müssen wir auch noch schneiden
und hier vorne habe ich noch ein paar
kürzungen stehen je nach frisur passt
das ganz gut
ein paar strähnen kürzer zu haben sag
mal mit hast du eigentlich schon etwas
abgeschnitten nein
dann kann ich das auch selber machen
stopp ich mache das selbst
ich mache das selbst noch das jetzt
alles selbst und um noch mehr solcher
vokabeln und sätze zu lernen möchten wir
euch unsere app sieht längen fehlen
dort könnt ihr nicht nur die grammatik
schritt für schritt lernen sondern auch
eure aussprache trainieren hier zum
beispiel könnt ihr eure aussprache
aufnehmen und mit der eines
muttersprachler vergleichen
so mag es jetzt hier alleine das geht
nämlich auch erst gerade erst mal noch
keinen zentimeter kann ich das probiere
warte oder habe
so jetzt sehe ich zumindest ein bisschen
da kann ich erst mal 'ne ganze ecke
abschneiden als andere mal an gott was
geht
[Musik]
wir sind fertig die haare sind wieder
gewöhnt wir hoffen ihr habt eine
vokabeln gelernt und ich muss dazu sagen
mit kann eigentlich sehr gut haare
schneiden
nun erzählt uns bitte eure füße
geschichten schreibt mal in die
kommentare ob ihr schon mal ein großes
missverständnis beim friseur hatte oder
andere lustige geschichten erlebt hat
und probiert mal unsere app ceiling aus
und trainiert dort vokabeln die
grammatik und eure aussprache bis bald
wenn man mit hast du eine schon was
abgeschnitten
dann kam ich das auch selber machen
[Musik]
strähnchen färben die gesamten haare
färben oder sehr typisches katzen